one other thing from Fox News that is
just laughable
Fox Nation which is the streaming
Network for Fox News they're doing a
mock trial of Hunter Biden yeah I no no
I didn't say Joe Biden they're doing a
mock trial of Hunter Biden you know they
talk about impeaching Joe Biden to which
we often say for what for what for what
but if they did a mock trial of Joe
Biden at least Joe Biden's the president
but that's not what they're doing they
are doing a mock trial for Hunter Biden
it's fiction programming okay take a
look at this promo Hunter Biden is the
most protected person in the country
what money laundering illegal foreign
lobbying
you have the laptop Infamous big guy
email
the son of vice president is doing deals
funded by the Chinese government
there are so many inclusive evidence
immediately ignored it because they
wanted Joe Biden elected president
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I am
here to defend Hunter Biden's wife
they were attempting to influence policy
objection your honor
let's look at photographs this is what I
think of these photographs we really
have no way of knowing what was said
between him and these people
80 command fabric your honor if you're
going to try my case you try not to lose
it
at this time the prosecution rests the
trial of Hunter Biden streaming all this
week
oh my goodness how can we even take this
seriously you know this could be so
devastating I don't know that anyone's
gonna vote for Hunter Biden after this
program oh he's not running for anything
oh fictional programming for their
endlessly gullible audience and again
we we see these interviews at a trump
rally and these people are obsessed with
Hunter Biden and we're like why where is
this stuff coming from it's coming from
places like this it's coming from this
type of programming uh Mr Biden you're
being charged with two counts of a
laptop from hell and two counts of the
Biden crime family how do you plea I
really wish they would stop trying to
make this Hunter Biden stuff happen but
it's also a reminder of how vapid and
vacant there they are in terms of having
anything else they don't have anything
else to work with this is all they have
at this point in time and yes I know
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
say that they're going to impeach Joe
Biden okay they seem they all seem much
much more focused on Hunter Biden it's
pathetic it's humiliating and again
remember one of the ways in which Fox
News has become what it is and Fox
Nation is the stream gaming arm of Fox
News one of the ways they've done it
is they blur the lines between reality
and fiction and they blur the lines
between news and opinion and
I do we call this a film I don't know
what I don't know if it's a series or a
film
this mock trial of Hunter Biden is the
epitome of appealing to low information
folks who lack all media literacy
blurring opinion and news fact and
fiction and hopefully nobody watches it
it looks like it's going to be a
complete and total disaster